days left of early voting the last day
for
early voting is on friday this year
nevadans can register to vote during
early voting
and on election day kate houston is live
in the southwest valley tonight at blue
diamond crossing
with everything you need to know if you
still need to register hi kate
hi good evening brian yes there's still
time to register to vote now you can do
that either
online or you can do it in person at a
polling site
just like the one here at blue diamond
crossing now here's how it works
if you'd like to do it online the
deadline is tomorrow october 29th
you can go to registertovotenv.gov
you can also register in person through
friday october 30
and on election day in order to do this
you do need to meet some requirements
such as being a u.s citizen and being at
least 18 years old
you'll also need unexpired current
nevada dmv
identification now while lines have been
running relatively smooth during early
voting
the election department recommends
registering at a polling location
with a smaller crowd at the malls
and some of the larger shopping centers
have certainly been some of our busier
spots and
they frequently will have a line some of
our community centers and recreation
centers that
are also polling places you know are
obviously a little less busy
the election department says the
software to check wait times is
not working as well as they had hoped
but you can still check
daily turnout numbers which break down
which polling sites are seeing the
biggest crowds
once registered you will vote on a
provisional ballot
it will be counted after verification
that you're qualified to register to
vote
and that you did not cast multiple
ballots in the same
election now back out here live behind
me you can see
the parking lot is a little full right
now there is a bit of a line it's grown
over the past 30 minutes since we've
been here
but hopefully it should go quickly and
people can get in and out
if they'd like to vote now i do want to
let you know there are
48 early voting sites where you can
register in person
there will also be 125 on election day
reporting live from blue diamond
crossing tonight kate houston 8 news now